hi i'm reza aslan and i'm rain wilson
and i am never sad liar
of course i am
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
so rain uh people tell me that you're
known for being funny i myself wouldn't
know i've never actually seen you in
anything um
do you think that there's anything to
this whole idea that you hear about all
the time about sort of you know the sad
clown or the tears of a clown you know i
will say that i have a lot of friends
that are comedic actors improv actors
stand up comics
and
for so many of them
comedy laughter
being funny meant survival
um
a lot of twisted upbringings a lot of
addiction yeah a lot of
family trauma a lot of just not fitting
in
and it wasn't just like funny like oh
i'm just gonna tell some jokes with my
friends because it's fun it's like
i need to be funny to transform my pain
into some kind of survival mechanism so
it's literally like the way that an
animal on a nature show grows oh look at
this six you know toad lizard that
needed its sixth toe so it wouldn't fall
off of this one species of tree it was a
survival mechanism that kind of comedy
came out of the same way so of course
there's gonna be sadness around that
when you're there's a kind of a
desperation around the funny i think
there's something deeper going on here
there's a there's this thing that
psychologists talk about when they they
say that in a way
you can't
experience happiness
without sadness right that you need
sadness
as a kind of comparative measure so that
you can experience happiness and so
that that link between
comedy and sadness between happiness and
sadness it's it's deeper than just
simply
one makes you forget the other but
comedy also explores reality
you know it pulls back the curtains on
the human condition and a big part of
the human condition is
is sadness you know we're we're alone
and we're separate from others and we
have pain and we recognize the pain in
others
it's a part of it's a part of being
alive and there are some comedians who
do this really well right like if you
were if you were
watching somebody on stage
talk about
their dead wife you know you would just
be like what the [ __ ] is happening i
don't even know
you know how to even process this story
about this guy talking about losing his
wife i i feel terrible everybody feels
terrible but if he went up there
and talked about his dead wife
by telling jokes
all of a sudden
i can absorb his sadness by laughing at
it right how many times have you been to
a funeral
in which you know people are up there
eulogizing the dead and it's just like
you know hilarious and everybody's
laughing and having a good time
it's almost like
comedy becomes a vehicle
yup to experience sadness in a safe way
so fortunately we've got a comedian here
and i'm not talking about me i'm not
really a comedian i'm just a weird actor
but michael ian black is a comedian
actor author he's written eight
children's books among some adult books
as well including one entitled i'm sad
yeah and we wanted to talk to michael
because we really wanted to dig deep
into this whole thing about what exactly
is so funny about sadness like why are
they why are they so intricately linked
together
and uh he seems like the perfect person
for this country he's kind of made a
career and it has a specialty around
introducing and exploring these tough
topics for kids in his books including
sadness so let us
welcome to the microphone direct from
connecticut
mr michael ian black he better be funny
[Music]
why did you write a book about sadness
for kids uh because i had written a book
called i'm bored
for kids which was uh a
a response to my own children
complaining of their own boredom
and
feeling like there was an opportunity to
write something sort of funny about that
um
and so i i wrote that book and it has
these three characters in it a little
girl
a potato
and a flamingo
and i and i really wanted to do
something with
those characters again and so i thought
well what could that be what could a
sequel to i'm bored b
and it seems obvious in retrospect that
you would just examine other sort of
uncommonly examined emotions in
children's literature but it took me
about it took me maybe four years to
figure that out
and what's the and what's the third in
the trilogy i'm i'm worried i'm working
oh you know there's a lot of
psychological research uh that shows
that sadness is really necessary to feel
happiness
that i would think you can't really
experience happiness without the sadness
so um are we in a culture that's trying
to erase sadness and trying to erase
boredom
um and in so doing is that one of the
reasons that we're
less happy and less fulfilled
well i do think and i'm you know i'm
talking about my butt um
that the charge against my generation
your generation of parenting is that we
are not only these helicopter parents
who are sort of constantly hovering but
also what's what's the word bulldozer
parents or something snowplow parents
we're sort of trying to shove obstacles
aside for our kids to sort of smooth the
path for them i think there's some merit
in that charge i
certainly see uh tendencies sometimes in
myself and in my wife to try to make
things always better for my kids
and i just instinctively
uh recoil from that instinct part of me
wants to do it and part of me is like no
they have to experience these things and
although we may have devices cell phones
to throw in their laps when they're
bored uh or we may have distractions for
them when they are sad or uh or we may
tell them fables when they are worried
i think kids have pretty sharp [ __ ]
detectors and know when they're being
lied to and know when
when a balm is being applied that isn't
going to
solve the problem you said something
earlier about
just even
helping kids to recognize
you know sadness and boredom
which is
something that i hear a lot from
parenting coaches that i've
uh how many parenting coaches do you
talk to well do you talk to a lot of
parenting coaches well it's a lot it's a
never mind
it's a very very long story and it has
to do with the fact that i live uh in
los angeles and that my four-year-old
went to a
this very very progressive
almost cult-like uh preschool and it
came with mandatory
parent training
and one of the things that
they talk a lot about is the inability
of a kid to be able to properly label
um an emotion so we do have a lot of
data scientific data that shows that for
for instance
many kids have a difficult time
differentiating between a sad face and a
mad face they don't know
what's the difference between the two we
also
have a lot of data showing that tantrums
are rooted in sadness and so i remember
this parenting coach told us
watch your kid watch your kid and then
and and the next time that they throw a
tantrum
notice how when the tantrum is over it
is
always followed by tears and sadness
and we watched and it's true that's
amazing i have never tantrum what about
that always end no matter what the
tantrum is about yeah no matter how
angry and violent the tantrum is it
always ends with sadness and tears
unprocessed sadness i don't know
which is why like this idea that a lot
of parents do which is well let them
work it out or i'm going to separate
myself from you like you would never do
that to a sad kid yeah so what are you
supposed to do though the opposite sit
there let it happen watch it happen
take part in it wait until it's over
wait till the tears come wrap them in
your arms and say it's okay oh like what
you would do if the if the kid was sad
yeah they better not try that at the
cheesecake factory when we go there i'm
telling you that right now
no cheesecake they're not gonna oh
they're not ruining my saturdays at the
cheesecake no
no way no they aren't known so
i guess all of this is to say that so
much of dealing with
a small kid's emotions
begins with just simply helping them
label it first like you're you're
worried that's what that's what's
happening right now you're sad that's
what's happening right now we're
thinking about the sadness in in
loneliness boredom anxiety
do you have a special insight as a as a
man of comedy as a sad clown into these
emotions
i think what comedians have
that maybe
other people have less of
is
an ability to
uh confront those feelings i don't think
we feel them any more acutely than
anybody else i don't think we feel them
with any more frequency than anybody
else but i think we're maybe more
willing to confront them
and and to confront them in a
constructive way can you guys expand on
that a little bit
well so much of what comedy
is comedy at root
is
rebellion
it is about finding incongruity in a
situation and exploiting it so
this is exactly why
uh very generally speaking and very
specifically speaking conservatives as a
as a sort of political leaning
aren't
funny
it's because conservation the concern
being a conservative is about preserving
the status quo it's about actually
embracing the congruous and saying i
like this thing and am fighting to
preserve this wow i think i've never
thought about that before that's that's
amazing it's a brilliant insight on mike
no it is keep going um and so
when you find yourself bumping up
against something you have an emotional
reaction to something whatever it is
um it could be observational like jerry
seinfeld you know why do they call them
grape nuts they're not grapes and
they're not nuts
when you bump into
i wish i could take credit for the first
time reigning her wish i could take
credit
so once you bump into that thing once
you bump into that thing that you're
having some sort of response to that's
an opportunity for comedy now that's a
surface one as you get deeper and you
and you bump into your own sort of
emotional problems and your own
emotional incongruity you recognize or
good comedians i hope recognize that
that
is um
those are opportunities for you to
express something in the way comedians
express these things is through comedy
through jokes so so you if you're a
musician it's the same thing if you're a
writer it's the same thing you know you
you're finding these moments of
incongruity and looking for ways to
resolve
[Music]
if you're thinking about breaking some
bad habits this year start with this one
overpaying for your prescriptions
to do that get in the good habit of
always checking good rx to help find the
best price for your prescription
medications i used to just visit one
pharmacy the one closest to me over here
not knowing that prescription prices can
vary between pharmacies by as much as a
hundred bucks
turns out i was paying way too much for
my prescriptions now
i always use goodrx to instantly find
discounts and compare prices at all the
pharmacies in my neighborhood look even
if you're like me and you have great
insurance you should still check goodrx
because it can often beat your copay you
can use their site or the goodrx app
which you can download for free goodrx
is free it's easy to use and you can
instantly save up to sometimes 80
percent plus it's accepted at over 70
000 pharmacies nationwide like cvs
kroger walgreens rite aid vaughn's
walmart
all those things you know i really had
no idea before i found out about goodrx
the fact that their the prescription
prices vary so much for simple smart
savings on your prescription check
goodrx go to
goodrx.com milkshake that is good rx dot
com slash milkshake good r x dot com
slash milkshake good rx is not insurance
but can be used instead of insurance in
2021 good rx users saved an average of
79
on retail prescription prices folks
did you know that only 9 of plastic
actually gets recycled reza oh
no matter how much plastic we put in our
recycling bin that is so depressing it
is so depressing but there is a company
grove collaborative
they believe it's time to ditch
single-use plastics for good grove
carries hundreds of products aimed at
replacing single-use plastics across
your home and personal care routine and
by 2025 grove will be 100 plastic free
like grove cos concentrated cleaners and
refillable glass bottles they're
friendlier to the planet and twice as
effective as the leading natural brands
switch to sustainable products for every
room in your home from laundry care to
hand soaps and more grovco has you
covered safe formulas refillable
packaging that never compromises on
performance i mean look i have three
bathrooms and four kids do you know how
many
just like hand pump soap bottles we go
through
in a week how many shampoo
bottles we go through
in a week that's like
enough plastic to cover a small island
essentially and so we totally take
advantage of grove we get these gigantic
things we fill all the old uh bottles of
shampoo and all the old bottles of of
hand soap over and over and over again
instead of just like tossing the plastic
in the recycling bin and then like
praying that it actually gets recycled
so join the over 2 million households
that are already shopping sustainably at
grove like we are all you got to do is
go to grove.com
milkshake today to get a free gift set
worth up to 50 with your first order
plus shipping is fast and free get
started right now at grove.com
milkshake that's grove.com
milkshake help save the world folks
but i i that's that's a fascinating
answer and uh i truly have gleaned a lot
from it but i will say that i disagree
because
myself i know i get to it's my podcast
um
you're just going to throw reza under
the bus like yeah yeah well
i'm just his handsome sidekick yeah he's
he's my better looking smarter i'm robin
so
you know i had a you know a
disassociated father who was not present
my mom left when i was two i had uh so i
was literally like
motherless between two and four or so
like not held and so it's created in me
after years of therapy i see like this
you know ungainly
awkward uh little child who
thought and he was he just could never
fit in in any way shape or form and then
i found like oh i could do weird things
with my body and i could make funny
faces and funny sounds or i could
you know ape people and i could um i
could make people laugh
and then all of a sudden i found a
belonging so there was through me a kind
of like i was able to transform the kind
of perverse anxious pain of my childhood
into making that whole big bundle of
money on the office
yeah well you just described you've just
described what i was saying well
no no problem
as a sad clown is because
of my suffering being transformed into
connection my disconnection my
alienation being transformed into
connection sure that's the positive that
is the the hoped for positive outcome of
any of these expressions
what rain is saying brings up this this
counterpoint in in another interesting
way because
and you and you said yourself that oh
it's the same thing that a musician does
or a songwriter does or an enact or does
but not really because a musician feels
the sadness and then expresses sadness
in a song that makes us all sad yeah
thank you
i feel pain and i'm rotten about that
an actor you know taps into that sadness
and then expresses sadness and then
gives
the emotion of sadness but a comedian
does the opposite a comedian
taps into that sadness turns it into
jokes and makes people happy so that's
yeah i guess
if the question that we're asking is
what's so funny about sadness which i
feel like that is that's pretty good
yeah what's so funny about sadness thank
you um
what is it then what is it about and why
is it especially michael that
so many comedians maybe it's a
stereotype but so many comedians
have this sort of gigantic well of
sadness you know that that they're
famous for
i don't think it's a stereotype i do
think that's true but i maintain
that
as
sad as comedians may be
they are no sadder than the general
population we are only perhaps more
aware of our own
sadness we are only maybe more tapped
into it i think that wellspring of
sadness that you're talking about is
ever-present i think it's a current that
runs through the entire human population
comedians
are are
maybe just uniquely wired to make that
transformation that you just described
of turning that that sort of alchemical
spinning straw into
gold um finding that sadness and and and
finding a take on it that people will
uh recognize and respond to with
laughter so it is a distinct art form of
course that turning sadness into into
laughter that is a that is distinct from
turning your own sadness into a sad song
or tapping into your own sadness to
express the words of somebody else like
an actor might do but i think at base
foundationally i think they're the same
thing so what's what was your sad clown
what's michael ian black at age 11 and
how has that been transformed into
through the work that you've done
one of the things that i really had to
struggle
with uh as
a comedian as a actor and as a human
is that
my response to my own
sadness
which i think really sort of descended
on me
for various reasons around the age of
five six
what i found was i could kind of shut
down emotionally and develop
this
sort of stoic
sarcastic side
that people found really funny i could
be really dry and i could say things in
a way that would make people laugh that
might might have been off-putting or
offensive if somebody else had said them
that turned into a whole career for me
um where i could be like the dry guy
but none of it
at least
i started to feel like it was a prison i
started to feel like that
character that i had created for myself
was
even as i was finding professional
success with it with it it was creating
um boundaries for me
as a human that i couldn't deal with
because my life wasn't reflecting
what my character was
doing and vice versa
and i felt like i needed to break out of
it and i also felt like there was a very
real chance
that that could sort of hurt me
professionally but that i needed to do
it just personally i needed to just to
scan and did you do that were you
effective in doing that
i did i mean
it started with um
so i was on these shows called the the
vh1 i love the whatever show i love the
70s i love the 80s i love the 90s and
those shows became really popular
and they were
funny and
i was funny on them
but what i was doing was sort of
like that was the height of my period of
being like incredibly just like
dry stone-faced
and that was that was the period for me
where i really started to feel like i
was kind of imprisoned and so to get out
of it i started
doing
stand-up which i hadn't done before
and exploring like what it was like to
be me as i experienced myself on stage
which was a new thing for me
and i also started writing
um and i wrote a memoir
called you're not doing it right which
was sort of an attempt to sort of
try to break out of some of this stuff
and it was and it was helpful it was
really funny were you in a therapeutic
process at this time it seems like no
you didn't you weren't because it seems
like something a therapist would would
be encouraging you to do it sounds like
you're almost do yeah i was just gonna
say yeah it sounds like great therapy
advice but it sounds like you were sort
of
internally doing it as therapy right
working this stuff out on a stage in the
form of jokes i was doing it all in a
very self-conscious way um or in a
conscious way i should say
and
it has been
for me like successful to a degree and
unsuccessful to a degree
because i knew comedically who that
other guy was
but the sort of
the person that is
me really mean
that's that has been a much harder nut
for me to crack on stage as a comedian
um
but but for me it's it's worth
that pursuit because
otherwise i
otherwise i worry that i i would end up
as a caricature of myself and i didn't
want to do that this way i feel like
my comedy can grow as i grow and my
comedy can go through the things that
i'm going through
do you think that there is something
unique about sadness
that allows it to be
more effectively communicated
if it's in the guise of comedy
like
i always find
that
when i'm watching a movie or a tv show
or or reading a book or whatever that
what i am
witnessing or experiencing is somebody
else's sadness
far from making me also feel sad it
makes me uncomfortable and embarrassed
and
it turns me off
or i just like instantly see it as fake
and
uncomfortable mostly uncomfortable
other people other people's sadness
makes me uncomfortable and i think i
think most people would agree with that
i don't know i don't know if that's true
at all no i think i wonder if that is
something specific to you and your
upbringing well by the way i don't mean
people i love i mean sort of no i don't
know what you mean or whatever like if
rain started crying right now i probably
would walk out i'd probably like i'm
gonna go get some coffee i'll be right
back wow
wow well no cause rain's a friend and i
love them and i'd hug them but you know
but but like if if if you know if our
sound engineer started crying i'd be
like oh robert oh dude i'm just uh i'm
gonna go outside for a little bit and
let you figure this out so what you're
describing is tension and comedy
is all about creating and releasing
tension that's genius okay that's
absolutely right that's the connection
so a good comedian
will take you
to an uncomfortable
place whether
it's it's uh it's it's a priest and a
rabbi walk into a bar we sense that
there's a tension that could arise from
there
and that setup is the tension the
punchline is the release of the tension
so when you have an uncomfortable
emotion like sadness and people do get
on i get uncomfortable if i see somebody
on the subway weeping or whatever i
don't know what to do that that that is
a natural
tension
jokes are the release are a perfect just
sort of valve for releasing that tension
that's what laughter is laughter is
literally it's it's it's a release of
tension
is there something also
uh yes i agree that in the communication
of sadness jokes can be a a pretty
powerful vehicle because of all the
reasons that you said because they have
a way of breaking through the tension
that just comes naturally when you're
confronted by
sadness in in some way um i think i
think
you know there's a there's a comedian
that we all know is a friend of ours
whose wife died suddenly
and
you know i didn't know how to respond to
him i mean he wrote me a lovely email
and i had no idea what to say except the
usual drivel you know like i'm sorry
sorry for your loss uh i wish there was
something you know whatever
and then that comedian did a special on
it
and i laughed my ass off through the
house why are you not saying patent
officer i don't know am i allowed to
like share somebody else's i don't know
if i were allowed to do this pat oswald
we all know this though yeah it's hard
but the point is is that
there was something about
seeing the sadness through the vehicle
of jokes that allowed me to connect to
him in a way that just his sadness
didn't
i i mean i haven't really thought about
this in that
in these terms before
he's
giving you
permission in a sense to laugh with him
to recognize
this very
common experience the experience of loss
he's also guiding you through it
so he's taking you on the journey with
him rather than asking
you to sort of walk with him
hand in hand which may be
some of that uncomfortability with the
email was it's like he's reaching out
and saying hey thank you this means a
lot to me you know i'm dealing with this
blah blah blah blah and you don't know
how to respond because
in a sense he's putting the ball in your
court and and asking you to either guide
him or walk with him in that setting in
the special he's he's saying i've got
this i'm taking you on this journey and
i'm going to
explain to you what i went through and
because i'm pat and hospital because i'm
so good at what i do
you're going to be safe in my hands and
you're going to laugh and maybe you'll
cry with me a little bit and and we'll
go through this together but i'm your
guide here in the moment
that would have been impossible
in the moment of his grieving in the
moment of his immediate morning that
wouldn't have been possible and it
wouldn't have been possible or
appropriate i think for you to take
those reigns and be like i got this
patton follow me
do you remember star trek in the episode
uh
spock's brain
where
spock melds with uh with the creature
and
uh i already know the whole thing melds
into the creature and the creature
has an experience of being in a human
body well in this case a vulcan body but
and the creature is like so alone you're
so alone
isn't isn't that part of
sadness like it's it's a real part of
being alive it's they call it an
existential sadness isn't it um
we're
we are separate
we are we are cut off
from
the unity of being from each other
now you're getting into theological [ __ ]
now you get into reza's wheelhouse all
right well maybe it's your wheelhouse
too i don't know so i'm talking about
here's one here
all right well i'll answer you
with uh
i'm gonna i'm paraphrasing from memory
because i'm gonna get it wrong but i
just wrote a book
about
boyhood and manhood and being a being a
man
and it's a letter to my son
and in it
i talk about losing my own
uh
dad
and how
i recognized something that the poet
eileen miles wrote about eileen wrote a
memoir called afterglow about their dog
rosie
and it's just a tiny moment where they
talk about
after rosie gets put to sleep
eileen is sitting there with rosie
and eileen talks about how we're here in
this little room
and outside is the world
and that's what
grief
and
solitude feel like to me
that we
experience so much of our lives alone in
this room with our dead dog whatever the
dead dog is
and we can't quite get through the walls
to let the world know that what feels
like the unconcerned world know
the depth of our own despair
i think that's the kind of aloneness
that you're talking about that
existential aloneness
but
what i think all the great traditions
teach
is that those walls are actually
illusory
that
given the right
tools or even just
being able to listen well enough you'll
hear
both the sadness and the joy that
everybody else is experiencing along
with you simultaneously but we have to
be able to tune into those things
comedy i think does a good job of being
those antennae comedy does a good job of
saying of just sort of focusing these
common experiences and projecting them
out in a way that is enjoyable
hey folks did you know that 90 of coffee
from the grocery store is actually stale
yes you heard that right the coffee you
know and you think you love it needs an
upgrade so instead of rebuying the same
old same old let trade coffee send you
something freshly roasted that you're
literally guaranteed to love
trade sells the freshest roasted and
ethically sourced beans from america's
best independent roasters this ship free
to you as often as you like whole or
ground whether you're a coffee nerd or
you just want a better daily cup trades
real coffee experts taste test over 400
roasts and use technology to match you
to your ideal coffee based on your
preferences and brewing method
take the coffee quiz to get started
trade coffee guarantees you'll love your
first bag or they'll replace it for free
the way it works is you go on their
website and you take like this coffee
personality test wow and it's like
when do you like to drink coffee how
often do you drink it what kinds of
coffee do you like do you get it at a
store you know do you like to grind your
own coffee how do you make the coffee do
you use a french press it's kind of fun
to sort of
learn about your coffee taste and then
this is the cool part
once they know like your coffee
personality yeah they find coffee from
these like roasters all over the country
you know like that one roaster in
seattle or that one great place in
baltimore
and they match you with that coffee and
then they just send it to you in the
mail it's it's actually a really cool
idea so it's like a coffee uh tinder
it's coffee tinder that's what it is
folks we're gonna tm that for our
listeners right now trade coffee is
offering a total of twenty dollars off
your first three bags when you go to
drinktrade.com
milkshake to get started take their quiz
at drinktrade.com
milkshake and start your journey to your
perfect cup
dot com that's
milkshake for twenty dollars off your
first three bags
take the quiz
but it turns out everything you know
about probiotics may be wrong rosa
i knew probiotic tortilla chips sounded
way too good to be true folks but good
news seeds daily symbiotic is the real
deal listen not all probiotics are
created equal okay what is a daily
symbiotic well it is a broad spectrum
two in one probiotic plus prebiotic
a proprietary formulation of 24 distinct
probiotic strains in scientifically
studied dosages proprietary engineered
two in one capsule that protects
probiotics through digestion to ensure
delivery to the colon
now if you've taken a probiotic before
and never felt a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria wasn't
surviving your gi tract this makes sense
common sense reza seed is designed
differently and that's why it works it
goes right to where the poop is
manufactured
so what does the daily symbiotic do for
you it supports benefits in and beyond
the gut yes seed will support ease of
bloating healthy regularity and ease of
evacuation
you know what i mean by that
it's pooping
but it will also support your gut
barrier skin health heart health and
micronutrient synthesis
i i got my uh jar of seed right here
folks although that does sound kind of
dirty now that i think about it it's
funny like my wife has been taking seed
for over a year and she swears by it and
you know whatever my my wife is a very
healthy person i never really took it
all that seriously and then suddenly i
get this jar of seed
myself to try out i've been taking it
all week and listen man i have been
pooping
it's been great
start a new healthy habit today all you
got to do is visit
seed.com
milkshake you can use the code milkshake
to redeem your 20 off that's 20 off your
first month of seeds daily synbiotic all
you got to do again go to seed.com
milkshake and use the code milkshake and
it's gonna be great poops from here on
out folks
you know the buddhists one of the the
central teaching of buddhism is that
life is suffering um are the noble
truths and
you know people in the east are are
generally much less sad than people in
the west four to ten times less sad
which is weird oh there's data there's
actually we have hard data on hard data
and but but i i think that we do
ourselves a disservice in the western
world by
uh constantly trying to shuffle off
sadness
undermine it soothe it put band-aids on
it and
how much better off we would be as a
society if
you know our belief systems were that
listen life is sad life is suffering the
nature of being alive is attachment to
things and those attachments will never
hold true and you will lose them and you
will feel bereft and that's part of the
game
and then there are obviously buddhist
tools to use to overcome that particular
type of sadness but i think we i think
we'd be in much better shape well
there's that
story about
soldiers in the u.s army who were sent
up to
the north pole sent up to alaska
somewhere very cold where they had to
perform functions
and
uh in terrible terrible terrible cold
and there were the inuit people there
who were able to perform these functions
with much
much greater ease than our soldiers and
they ran some studies to determine
why were the inuits actually
experiencing the cold less
than our soldiers
and it turns out that no they weren't
it's just that they accepted it they
just knew that it was a part of their
lives
and they
could deal with it because it was just
it was just as plain as the nose in
front of their faces whereas
our soldiers on accustomed to it and and
having uh come from a place that that
that
they didn't have this unremitting cold
couldn't handle the change and i think
that's true with what you're what you're
describing i think that's true with
sadness when when we when we try to
shuffle it off like you said and we
can't just sit with it yeah we're going
to experience it more acutely because we
feel like there's something wrong with
it when there's not it's just it's just
what it is
if you could snap your fingers
i can it's not that hard oh all right
wow well thank you michael thanks so
much
what i meant to say was if you could
step your fingers
and just never feel sad again
from here on out
would you do it
no i don't think anybody would i don't
think anybody would i'd be amazed if
anybody would take that deal because
like you said at the beginning of the
conversation reign you you know
that that would also kill your joy you
couldn't feel joy if you didn't feel
it's opposite
ladies and gentlemen this has been
michael ian black killer of joy
[Laughter]
we've got a lightning round of questions
okay you can give us a a a brief first
impression response number one boom
hold on but first let me express some
anxiety that i'm having
uh and worry uh oh because this is and
this has been this just goes back to
what we were talking about
my worry in appearing on your podcast is
oh gee i wasn't
uh funny enough and i had to give myself
sort of permission years ago this was
sort of this whole process that i was
talking about of not
feeling the need to entertain and be
funny in the way that necessarily people
expect me to so like i have to sit with
that own like discomfort
uh even when i'm even when i'm going
through it let's just sit with michael
ian black's discomfort hey just between
you and me i was in the impression that
he would be funny
didn't you think i felt like that's what
we signed up for i thought he was gonna
be a lot funnier yeah whatever don't
don't tell him he can't hear us right no
the i have the mute button pressed it's
good yeah but i could hear you that
whole wait watch oh my god
okay lightning round
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
uh
about 4 00 am if i'm awake
what makes you laugh out loud
uh things my kids say they you know kids
they say the darndest i've heard that
yeah i've heard that before describe
your soul in 10 words or less
okay this is the lightning round uh i'm
gonna go with uh uh like a bridge over
troubled water i will lay me down
how many words is that
it's ten it's eleven i think it's eleven
so i will just lay me as all you can get
okay fine
and uh what is your biggest fear
um uh that that i'm not good enough
what's one thing you know for sure
uh that i'm getting fatter
yeah i could tell and then finally
what is your life's big question
the nice thing is i feel like whatever
big questions i had for my life have
already been resolved
i
i i'm i'm fairly at peace uh with
all the questions that i had the sort of
bigger questions that i had
the only question left really is uh on a
daily basis is what are we having for
dinner
yeah which consumes a lot of my mental
energy by the way i get it we have kids
and you know what it is you know what
the answer is
squad please tell me tacos oh i knew it
was gonna be squad i thought you were
going to say sadness
tears
we're having tears for dinner just squad
thank you so much thank you so much
you're welcome this has been a delight
in so many ways
you know
what i was thinking about we've been
talking about sadness for a while now
half an hour 40 minutes and it's it's
really hard to define
sadness isn't it it's it's does it feel
broad it feels kind of
general is there a way that we can get
more specific about discussing sadness i
mean how do you define it how do you how
do you dig into precisely what it means
and more importantly
separate it from depression i mean we
don't want to right there are people
depression is a as a mental illness yeah
it's a psychological condition it's
serious it requires therapy it requires
drugs like that's a serious thing that's
not what we're talking about and we got
to separate it from loneliness because
we already did an episode on something
we already did yeah so let's not talk
about loneliness we're talking about
sadness so sadness i guess is
situational i sometimes don't you feel
sad without any situation like
everything is just fine and you just
feel sad
yes that is absolutely true sometimes i
think i just feel sad and i don't know
why sometimes
i kind of relish feeling sad do you ever
do that do you ever like sure
sure like
there's some i don't know it's weird you
kind of want to hang on to it it has a
kind of uh i want to let it go yeah a
sentimental attachment to that yes to
that sadness but you know it's
interesting um we got a list of words
from our great producer amy choi uh from
other languages that describe very
specific types of sadness and they don't
have an exact equivalent in english and
i thought this was really interesting
you know like what is it the the inuit
have like 37 words for snow or something
like that like we only have one um so
it's good to kind of like define sadness
a little more specifically here's a
language i've never heard called a lutik
alutik
um
and
the word is
and it's
i am sad in that's the phrase but it
literally translates as i am searching
for my content oh my god i love that i'm
searching i'm searching contents
so in chinese
the word for sad which i'm not gonna
butcher no you have to butcher it oh for
[ __ ] okay here we go i apologize to
all of my chinese friends
beiji xiaohuji beijing is good
uh
and that's that's
literally translated as sad and happy
intersecting ah i've felt that before
yeah have you felt that before that i
think that's what we're talking about
when you want to like relish your
sadness and in check uh crossosmutinen
uh literally means beautiful sadness
um
germ no one who knows anything about
german will be surprised about
the word for sadness in german which is
welsh smears
well
welsh smells
because it literally translates as world
a deep existential sadness caused by the
condition of the world which i'm feeling
a little bit
right now because
in french there's a i'm terrible at
french i cannot speak uh
vague a lame literally translates as
vague soul a kind of gentle wistful
sadness one more swedish vemmod
i like this because it's basically what
it means is melancholy but with a layer
of pensiveness
and or nostalgia
so it's like pensive sad all of this is
to say that there are many many
different kinds of sadness
and we feel it on multiple levels it has
deeper meanings some of it is the kind
of sadness that you want to relish some
of it is sadness that you want to get
rid of but the bottom line is is that
the sharing of sadness
seems to work better when the vehicle of
that sharing
is humor it's comedy
it's a way of experiencing somebody
else's sadness without it becoming
maudlin
milkshakers listen as you know we love
to get uh listeners on the show we love
to hear about your life's biggest
possible questions i mean love really i
don't know if like we like we like to
i love it
i love it i think you know we didn't
start the show this way we added as an
added component to the show and
and frankly i i love it i don't want to
just talk to authors and phds i want to
talk to the real people want to keep it
real you know
if it were up to me it would just be two
hours of me just talking
i i am very very aware of that
i am very aware of that so anyways folks
um if you're done reza you can leave us
uh there's several ways to do that write
in to us on social media uh this is uh
at reza aslan rayne wilson at
metaphysical milkshake on instagram at
metamokpodcast
on twitter
and you can leave us a positive review
on apple podcasts with your life's big
question and we will pluck you from the
thousands of positive glowing reviews
and bring you on the show and today we
are thrilled to have someone with the
unlikely name of noah della pietro
hello everybody
you know how there was this ancient
debate between the ethos of jerusalem
and the ethos of rome
well noah de la pietro is balancing
jerusalem you're
so noah what uh what brings you to the
show you got a question for us what do
you want to talk about
yeah uh this is something that's always
been fascinating for me and um
you know we all watch movies tv all the
time and i think this question is
something super relevant right now so
it's a little bit of a big one but
with the dissipation of cable streaming
services are like now becoming like
fragmented packages of what cable
originally was so do you think we're
going to continue to see media divided
up by the platform and if so how would
it affect society and culture when
instead of a few media sources there's
just a bit a ton of like niche ones
behind different paywalls i've seen you
know with netflix kind of exploding the
last few years and um now we're seeing
all these other channels kind of have
their own network i've been curious to
see kind of what's going to be the
future of this uh noah can i ask you a
question where are you calling from
i'm calling from los angeles
only
only
a guy calling from los angeles would a
question about the dissipation
of distribution platforms
be an existential question
am i right
went to school for film work in media so
you know it's something that's always on
my mind yeah
uh you know look uh for i just i feel
like
reyna and i like think and talk about
stuff like this all the time but i'm
assuming most of our listeners do not
but i mean you all remember when there
were like three channels right there was
abc nbc and there was cbc and then you
remember do you remember rain when like
there was suddenly fox and we were all
like whoa whoa
four channels crazy
insane
and then there was this thing called
basic cable and like we all had like
suddenly these weird channels where we
were like amc and you can watch like you
know old western movies like 24 7.
remember that like and remember that all
of these channels like bravo had like
operas
yes
bravo was just like music
yeah and uh and vh1 was video hits one
it was non-stop music videos
so uh and then we remember but do you
remember when we were like holy [ __ ]
there's like 10 channels now
yeah i mean it's like 11 channels
there's so much what am i gonna watch
and then bruce springsteen sang that
song 57 channels and there's nothing on
yep yeah
and now
i mean
you know it's like
there's just too much there's just one
way to get wait
to try and get
existential about it i mean i think that
what we're seeing i mean this is talked
about a lot in the news media but
this kind of like compartmentalization
siloization where
you can pick and choose
where what your entertainment is and
um where you get your news where you get
your information where you get your
entertainment so
you can
you know you can sit in a house in los
angeles and just watch
msnbc and sundance channel artsy films
and uh
and then you can sit in a house in
oklahoma and you can watch fox news and
listen to christian podcasts and
uh miracle network or whatever i'm doing
very broad generalizations here but the
the problem is is
there is so little shared culture
anymore that
um
we're breaking up into these factions so
there's a lot of positive to it you know
you can literally spend the time
watching and consuming the content that
you're actually interested in
uh
but
uh we as america has have always used
kind of like shared media to kind of
unite us in a weird way you know is
walter cronkite you know bringing all of
america together with his you know his
sonarus
tones as a newscaster his
trustworthiness
uh which is now evaporated so
you know where does this go you know we
have to find a different way
to try and seek some kind of unity or
we'll just fracture more and more so
you know is this a sign of the
apocalypse reza what do you think
well you know it's fun because we did
that we did that amazing episode with
dave kaplan yeah which noah you should
definitely go back and listen to can tv
save the world
and dave kaplan had this whole theory
that made so much sense to me
which was you know the television is the
new family hearth right we used to have
this thing
before tv
called the hearth in every house and we
would all you know families would gather
around it and it was kind of where the
community was and then of course he even
goes further back in time and he's like
you know there was like the community
heart like the village would all get
together and listen to the uh the bard
or the or the shaman you know tell the
great stories and myths
of the community
go all the way back to the cave right we
would all gather around the fireplace
and we'd all talk about the hunt
that happened but it was a way of
creating precisely the sense of
communal identity that rain was just
talking about
um and then tv did that for a while
right yeah rain's right not just walter
cronkite but like the jeffersons happy
days
like good times we would all get
together we'd watch it at a precisely 8
30 you know on thursday even friends in
seinfeld even friends in seinfeld and
the office when it began was kind of the
last
modern family i think was on after us
but it was kind of the last or one of
the last kind of
shared television only commun cultural
experience yeah yeah and then
but now
that's gone right now first of all we
don't all watch tv anymore anywhere we
watch it on our phones we watch it very
much privately we don't watch it as a
family that much anymore like the idea
that they
absolutely
and so to your question
how will it affect society and culture
i think
we're seeing that right we talk so much
about how polarized and fractured we are
as a country
and we talk about it as though it's
because of politics
it ain't because of politics and it's
certainly by the way not because of
opinions it's funny because as much as
we talk about how divided we are as a
country
when you actually start polling people
about their beliefs and their views
there's actually a lot of unanimity in
the way that we think about you know
cultural and societal even climate
change health care education
it's unbelievable right yeah the
political party that would not want you
to believe that you know but it's true
yeah
so
i think the issue here then is
um
is it just a reflection of a fractured
society or is it creating the fracturing
of society
and i'm definitely much more in the
latter category you know i think because
we're not in some in a lot of our views
especially with the really big stuff
we're not all that far apart
but because we don't ever have to
connect with each other anymore because
there isn't a
shared space where we all go to and then
we can all have a conversation about you
know what we all experience with the
with the possible exception of like the
super bowl
you know um
it's
it is definitely
promoting
the the sort of
fracturing of this kind of larger
collective identity that we used to have
but i don't i don't really see it
changing
i don't know
no what do you think
i don't know i mean when you guys were
mentioning about like old shows everyone
kind of coming together watching that
i'm just thinking of like
i was in the pool of missing out but i
didn't watch game of thrones when it was
on but i know everybody that i knew was
watching it and anytime i'd hop on
twitter or any social media you know i'd
see people
all coming together like oh did you
watch that new episode or whatever and
i mean what i see nowadays i guess with
different television shows it's
where where i was kind of getting at
where it feels a lot more niche because
for example there's this new uh animated
cartoon on adult swim that a lot of
people are watching there's ads for all
around la and um
i uh it it wasn't on hbo max and it
originally it was just on adult swim
like you had to pay obviously to watch
it um i watched it it was a few a few
people i knew watched it but now that
it's on hbo max i'm seeing it all over
tick tock i'm seeing it all over youtube
like little clips and all that and it's
interesting because it's it's you you
know that it's getting bigger because of
the people that have hbo max that are
watching it through that so
i don't know it is interesting like now
hearing your guys what you guys have to
say like
in some cases it's bringing a lot of
people together with these different
services because it's different
communities i guess and different
like certain shows on certain networks
certain shows are on certain like
platforms so it's it's bringing people
together in like smaller ways i guess
but then i guess where i'm coming from
at the same time it might be separating
people because if someone can't afford
hbo max or
showtime or something like you know it's
like
i'm damn i'm missing out or something
you know no one watches showtime dude
yeah my dad knows but you know
also these platforms are
global platforms right yeah so you think
about netflix squid games um
yeah i mean
people watching it in iceland and
mongolia
and that that sort of connects you in
this weird way that like something on
cbs could never connect you
um you know but but i do think that it
is a it is really
indicative of the way you know we
complained so much about the internet
creating these bubbles right that the
idea was like i mean i remember when the
internet
began to be a thing
and
people like me were like this is amazing
we are going to have access to new
sources of knowledge and information
it's going to create a global community
instead of these different you know
communities that are you know
geographically contained uh
yeah so sweet so sweet
yeah we had the idea like oh all the
information is going to be out there so
if someone has a question about vaccines
they can google it
they can you know they can do their own
research and they can do their own
research and look at the data and they
won't just listen to their uncle stan
they'll really dive into the science of
it
oh no man
man oh man
well you were you were of a younger
generation than us noah and especially
of me so we're counting on you to uh
lead the way forward in this fractured
world and fractured media landscape
uh to do something that unites us and
binds us toward a commonality of helping
the poorest
and the most destitute among us and
leading humanity forward what do you say
save us noah
says
you're our only hope i will do it yeah i
will do it i will try my best all right
thanks for coming on folks uh leave your
life's big questions on the apple
podcast review or write us on social
media you can find us just google it
you'll figure it out we'd love to hear
from you thanks for coming on noah
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang
it was produced by amy s choi and
rebecca lehrer of the mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowderwill sarah pellegrini
mary phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
i love the 80s they should have the i
love the 1870s they're not i'll be on
that you know like i love those big
wheeled bicycles oh look at this guy
riding around i'm writing this down
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you